[Music]
researchers at Cornell decided to figure
out some practical uses for an extra
robotic arm they discovered it's more
useful for professional and work
settings where it's helpful to hold
multiple things at once rather than
recreational uses like an extra arm for
rock climbing although that would be
cool and also at guy Hoffman's lab
blossom is a social home robot made out
of soft handcrafted materials like yarn
and wood instead of the usual plastic
glass and metal honestly I just wanted
to show you this because it's the first
companion robot I've wanted to hug
Vsauce Kevin here this is mind blow
[Music]
Ohio State researchers have a OneTouch
organ healing device the tissue nano
transfection technology allows doctors
to generate any cell type within a
patient's body to repair injured tissue
or restore organs blood vessels and
nerve cells by placing the chip on the
body and applying electrical current the
non-invasive reprogramming turns skin
cells into whatever cells doctors need
it injects DNA into the skin cells and
it worked on a mouse to restore blood
flow to a damaged leg in just three
weeks and they're beginning human
clinical trials for this in 2018 we may
have discovered the building blocks for
quantum internet researchers at the
Australian National University used an
ion called erbium in a crystal to store
quantum information for over a second
ten thousand times longer than previous
experiments it also works with existing
fiber-optic networks and can connect to
different quantum computers and one
great advantage of developing the
quantum Internet is security would allow
for information to be destroyed if
intercepted there is a pen that can
detect cancer in real time the mass spec
pen developed at the University of Texas
at Austin works by delivering a water
droplet to a tissue surface which
extracts biomolecules which are then
delivered to a mass spectrometer for
molecular analysis the system then tell
surgeons whether the tissue is cancerous
or not in seconds allowing for safer and
more effective cancer removal surgery
the first winged mammals evolved 100
million years earlier than the first
modern mammal Flyers to 160 million year
old Jurassic period fossils were
uncovered in China and a collaboration
between the University of Chicago and
Beijing Museum of Natural History
resulted in these awesome
reconstructions and this discovery shows
the ecological diversity of early
mammals suggesting dinosaurs were not
quite as dominant as previously thought
nerble created the first brain
controlled virtual reality game the
brain computer interface company
interprets
activity using an EEG to measure
electric activity and software to
translate it into action their device
uses seven electrodes that measure
signals responding to stimuli so you can
play their game awakenings without
controllers you literally just use your
brain the plan is to make this available
in VR arcades next year meanwhile in
Japan rural elderly folks are getting
around in autonomous robot buses they've
begun experimenting with driverless
buses to shuttle the elderly to medical
and shopping services in rural areas
without enough workers to drive taxis or
buses right now the robot shuttle tops
out at 6 miles per hour so hopefully as
they develop the technology they can
improve the travel time before their
projected launch in 2020 nano biotics
are a new class of antibiotics engineers
from Michigan University can create
nanoparticles 1/100 the size of a germ
of different shapes to control what they
do so by using these to coat medical
devices they bind to the proteins to
prevent molecules from changing thereby
creating bacterial resistance which
could be a huge advance in the fight
against antibiotic resistance scientists
at the University of Texas at Dallas
have developed electricity generating
yarn the carbon nanotube twist drawn
yarn generates electricity when
stretched and one of the future uses of
this technology could be harvesting
energy from ocean waves finally smart
self-driving wheelchairs are continuing
their development with hospital trials
in Singapore the technology will give
people much more flexibility and much
richer personal mobility and at the same
time it will make it better for the
doctors and the nurses
we'll focus on patient care and we'll be
less worried about whether they have the
right object or the right people in the
right place over the years mind blow has
focused on breakthrough ideas
discoveries and science to push us all
forward the world has spent on an
incredible path of progress in our
lifetimes we've witnessed the biggest
decrease in poverty disease and child
deaths but progress is not inevitable
so the Gates Foundation is creating the
goal keepers report which they hope will
inspire a new generation of leaders goal
keepers who raise awareness of progress
hold their leaders accountable and drive
action to accelerate progress education
is an area where the world doesn't have
enough data to understand progress it's
relatively easy to count the number of
children and school but that doesn't
tell us how much those children are
actually learning many countries don't
generate any useful learning data at all
let alone in a comparable way we need to
know early whether children are able to
read a prerequisite to all learning so
for more information on ways to get
involved in ensuring quality education
to transform our world click the link to
read the report now I'm gonna leave you
with two walking robots taking a stroll
through the agility robotics office and
as always thanks for watching
[Music]
[Music]
the art of bookmaking is older than
printing by many centuries yet today's
members of the Brotherhood of
bookbinders artists of the AF of l-cio
are able to supply the demand for the
most important ingredient of the modern
world literacy following a craft as
ancient as cave drawings these union
workers of the book industry are second
to none in keeping pace with progress
the ingenuity which has been passed on
to the folders gatherers sewers trimmers
liners and case makers in a proud
profession is constantly at work for you
to produce our greatest treasure
knowledge
[Music]
you